we're armed with hashtags
where i come from respect for authority
almost silenced us see we are taught
from a very young age never to speak
back to elders and especially those in
positions of influence and authority but
this is changing and that's all thanks
to social media there's a young
generation of kenyans who are using this
space as a safe place for descent young
people like me are watching in real time
how the world around them is
surprisingly similar and using online
spaces to create global conversations i
remember hearing about officials in our
sports ministry allegedly
misappropriating funds meant for olympic
athletes young kenyans armed with
nothing really but hashtags took to
twitter and facebook and they made their
voice heard it was a perfect example of
brotherhood nationalism and a call for
accountability
140 characters at a time it's really
important for me to listen to these
emerging voices of this young continent
and tell their stories my name is edith
kimani and i work at dw
[Music]